the film searches aren't so many
different themes one that really stood
out to me was the kind of immense inner
strength that women have is that quite
important to you when you're taking on a
role to portray that I mean I'm always
going to be more attracted to women who
have some kind of conflict to play and
something that's not just a
two-dimensional character so yeah that's
always the draw is to play a character
with depth and and a sense of meaning
and not just to sort of reactionary role
to a male co-star you know but I think
strength is not necessarily the word
that I look for I look for complexity
and because you know it's that funny
thing that no one ever describes a male
character is like wow that's a really
strong character it's sort of and I feel
like the same should go for female roles
as well we should just accept people as
being complicated and flawed and you
know everything that people that women
are you know so one of the most tense
and emotional moments in the film is the
bathtub scene I was riding in my seat
because it was so stressful
obviously labor is such a difficult
thing and with added circumstances it
must have been quite a stressful
headspace akin to yeah I mean I think it
was quite a stressful yes it meant we
shot it over five days that from start
to finish from the moment the water
breaks till the moment that you worked
had you squirming the master I feel like
everyone on set was like crossing their
legs but it was an exhausting sequence I
will say that but ultimately I knew
there was gonna be it was gonna pack a
punch yeah you're a little excited by
doing those sequences because you know
what it'll mean to an audience yeah see
you and John I've obviously worked
together quite a few times and you
married not really worked there wasn't
the boys so with this film the dialogue
was quite different as in yeah was a
very much of it did you find that you
learn anything about each other while
you were working together because it was
less talking going on I mean the only
thing I can think of is that in some
ways you are a slightly different person
when you're at work and and I think that
that was the thing we were a bit nervous
about is whether we'd be able to embrace
that about the person you know that this
is not domestic life when you're on set
and and I think we the only things that
surprised us was sort of just how well
we collaborated together and I think
everything else when it came to his
ability and his talent as a director and
as a filmmaker and a visionary person
was something I've always known about
him and I was just more excited for
people to find that out too your career
has gone from straight strength which
obviously means a lot of traveling a lot
of Nate late nights a lot of early
mornings have you got any wellness hacks
that you kind of picked up along the
road that you want to share with our
followers I would say if you feel
yourself coming down with a cold which
I'm like the worst person to nominate
those because I sound horrible today l
end of laryngitis but but I do find oil
of oregano all of our ago my salmon it's
so used to hearing that emotion oil of
Oregon I know when I asked when I asked
for a gardener out there they're like
what it's like oregano but you'd
actually sort of just throw a few drops
down there
it's disgusting you burn your throat but
I do tend to find it shortens the cold
awesome and are there any beauty
products that you swear by that our
followers should know about anything
you've used forever and ever well I
absolutely love Sicily products I think
they are beautiful I love them and Plato
podu the most fantastic little lemon
foundation sticks I love them concealer
sticks I should say cuz I've got a bit
of a quick fire round come on then um
just to either all so my scar oil
lipstick
fish or chips Oh chips beach holiday or
a city break hmm quite like a city break
now
cool Madonna or Britney Oh full glam or
all-natural all-natural and horror films
or rom-coms rom-coms